[Applause]
he's a retired General who is once a
senior official in the NATO alliance now
at the age of 61 Petra Pavel has been
elected president of the Czech Republic
he's promised to be a dignified
president for all the country's 10 and a
half million people
I understand that there are some who are
disappointed because their favorite
candidate did not win but I also see
that in this country we do not have
winning or losing voters I see that
values won in this election values such
as truth dignity respect and humility
as predicted Pavel easily beat his 68
year old rival Andrei babish a
billionaire who served as prime minister
between 2017 and 2021.
babishi's closeness to outgoing
president milosh zemat may have hindered
him zaman's a divisive figure who
developed close ties with Moscow before
making a U-turn when Russia invaded
Ukraine last year
Petro Pavel unlike his rival came out
strongly in favor of further military
aid for Ukraine he was always the
favorite despite Revelations he'd
received training in Military
Intelligence in the former
Czechoslovakia when it was ruled by
Communists backed by Moscow
the Czech president to point to the
Prime Minister as well as constitutional
judges but the results unlikely to
significantly change the country's
foreign policy Nadine barber Al Jazeera